the supreme court hears arguments this
morning in a case that could allow
states to outlaw abortion for the first
time since a roe versus wade decision
nearly 50 years ago
the justices must now decide whether to
uphold mississippi's ban on abortions
after 15 weeks jan crawford is at the
supreme court with more on this story
jan good morning to you
good morning gail there are protesters
here already on both sides thousands
more thousands are expected by the time
the supreme court finishes arguments in
this case it really could determine the
future of abortion rights in america and
it's a case that started in the deep
south at a clinic known as the pink
house in jackson mississippi
shannon brewer has spent most of her
working life on the front lines in the
fight over abortion this is the one that
i can honestly say
worries me more than any of them in 20
years at jackson women's health
organization she's come to expect
protesters and his long head escorts to
help the patients inside we're out here
trying to guide them all through it for
years the doctors here at mississippi's
only abortion clinic have flown in from
out of state and tried to stay anonymous
there's only a few of us that are
available to come to this state
so
if i stop doing it and one or two others
stop doing it then the state's in a very
precarious position but brewer says the
biggest threat now is from the courts
they're allowing
things to get through that weren't
getting through before
that's what abortion rights opponents
like debbie goodman whose protest wasn't
with a bullhorn but a quiet prayer have
long hoped for i believe in the power of
prayer and i did get a little emotional
i'm doing it again
i just feel like prayer works
and you know if i think about what's
happening possibly there right now it
just
breaks my heart jackson women's health
sees 70 to 80 patients a week including
some women who travel hundreds of miles
from texas in september that state
banned almost all abortions after about
six weeks the supreme court is
considering a challenge to the texas law
but it's today's mississippi case that
could overturn roe versus wade the
almost 50-year precedent that prohibits
states from banning abortions before a
fetus can survive outside the womb at
about 24 weeks with three new
conservative justices all appointed by
former president trump who supported
overturning roe some see this case as
their best chance i do hope that they
outlaw robbie
and conservative-leaning states are
ready 21 states already passed laws to
ban all or almost all abortions if roe
is overturned while more liberal states
are taking steps to protect access to
abortion back in jackson brewer says she
knows what would happen they would
definitely ban abortion in mississippi
immediately
yes in several other states too
now the court of public opinion also is
weighing in a cbs news poll found a two
to one majority supports keeping roe
versus wade in place with some americans
saying that that would be a backward
step for women but if roe is overturned
most americans say there should still be
some restrictions on abortion vlad
50 years of presidents hanging in the
balance jan thank you very much